oh ross this is the best week ever me
too
true i'm so happy okay 2020
i think that we could all use a little
centering
and now chris hemsworth is gonna help
what do you know rob well he's helping
in many many different ways am i right
ladies and gentlemen
we all saw chris become an incredibly
ripped god in the thor movies and now
he's sharing his fitness and meditation
secrets
on a new app drew it's called center
download people uh reports that chris is
sharing daily affirmations on the app
and to kick it all off he posted this
video of himself trying to meditate
underwater because that's how chris
hemsworth does it and his his son is
being a little distracting
my question is this he's going to post
meal plans exercise
all that stuff on the app but if i don't
end up looking like him do i get my
money back
is that is that fair i mean i say
if cr geez look at that picture i mean
it's almost like i have to avert my eyes
oh you don't have to avert anything i
have to say i find him so soothing
and um you know his voice
his voice it's very asmr that is a good
word for it
yeah everything he's soothing and total
inspo hashtag chris hemmer
chris hemsworth goals yeah i'm
downloading that app i think we all are
okay and now huffpost reports that plato
has launched a new line
called play-doh for grown-ups uh it's
about time
i know i love play-doh so much i used to
like try to eat it when i was a kid
didn't we all
the scented play-doh includes thank you
yes everybody's nodding
aromas like overpriced latte i have that
one here
okay and then there's grill king i have
that one right here
real quick and then there's spa day you
know all the stuff adults like
oh okay right i'm into the spa day
this is green grass the one i'm doing
now and does it smell like green grass
like if green grass was play-doh okay
ross
what scent would you request to plato to
have chris hensworth that's the
yes yes perfect thank you people at
plato thank you so much
i love it oh thank you plato okay and
our next story ross take it away okay
hold on oh
oh in our ongoing desperation for fall
spirit because it's fall out there we
want to feel it uh there's a new product
in town the new york post reports that
buy right as a boutique in san francisco
they're selling a
bouquet of organic fall leaves
for the low price of fifteen dollars
they're really branching out is it do
you think that one man's lawn garbage is
another man's 15
treasure well you know i grew up in
california where there's like
perennial foliage everywhere all day all
night and all year
but now that i live in new york i could
i have like gone and gotten some bodega
leaves for decoration like get my
joanna gaines on by the way this
play-doh is really addictive is this not
the most soothing thing in the world to
just squeeze
literally my t my daughter's teachers
are like we don't allow things in the
classroom but we want olive to play with
her squishies and her slime because it's
very therapeutic
and i really understand that uh-huh all
right
now as all the men in our lives slowly
turn into lumberjacks around us
clear men have stopped shaving this
pandemic but now
people magazine reports that while men's
razor sales are down
women's razor sales keep climbing i
totally get it
why because at first i read this i
didn't understand why well i guess you
know
for those who go to a waxer you know
it's not sort of
attainable right now and so you're at
home
and you need to do a little gardening
and
you know like i shaved my legs the other
day
and i have to say it felt really good
yeah what do you think about getting
crazy in the like winter months
but what do you think about the men who
are all growing out during the
quarantine cause some of them
look straight up like santa well ross i
mean you have such a beautiful baby face
do you shave like
moments before we come on air you know i
did have a beard once in high school she
was a sweet girl
oh gosh i love you oh thank you for
being here and i can't wait
for tomorrow when we go to the weekender
and we have a big halloween show oh
stay tuned everybody we got costumes
coming up boss and i are getting all
dressed up so is everyone that's coming
on the show with surprises
you